[Music]
to celebrate hispanic heritage month
we're going to do it one of the best
ways we know how and that's by taking a
look at five essential spanish language
films
on the ketchup with the help of film
critic and journalist monica castillo we
curated a list of the 110 essential
spanish language movies at
rottentomatoes.com and it is filled with
some classic favorites
festival winners and even a few oscar
contenders
we're looking at the top five on that
list starting with a short film from
1965 called simon of the desert now this
venice film festival winner is a hundred
percent fresh and is about a deeply
religious man living in the fourth
century simon
who climbs the stone column in the
middle of the desert and prays for six
years six weeks and six days while the
devil tries to seduce him to calm down
i can totally relate and coming in at
number four is the 2001 film
la cienega it is a certified fresh
dramedy from highly decorated
argentinian director
lucretia martell and this one follows a
group of families having summer vacation
in a rural country house in argentina
with the critics calling it
dense yet impressively focused and a
disquieting look at domestic
dissatisfaction
[Music]
number three on our list is 1999's all
about my mother from acclaimed writer
director pedro almodovar
this certified fresh film is about a
heartbroken mother who goes in search of
her son's father now a trans woman
after her son is tragically killed in a
car accident with a cast that includes
cecilia roth and penelope cruz
this drama won both an oscar and a
golden globe for best foreign language
film
finding its way to number two on this
list is of course 2006 pans labyrinth
it was written and directed by the
guillermo del toro and follows the young
stepdaughter of a sadistic army officer
as she escapes into an eerie but
captivating fantasy world this film
which critics call a
spellbinding fable that's like alice in
wonderland but for grownups is really
all about the visuals considering it
picked up oscars for cinematography art
direction
and makeup and finally number one on our
list of the 110
essential spanish language movies is
2018's roma
this drama was shot on location in
mexico city and is heavily based on
writer director alfonso cuadron's
real-life nanny when he was a child in
the early 1970s
smartly released on netflix this film
became the streaming service's first
film to be nominated for best picture
and ended up taking home gold statues
for directing foreign language film
and cinematography
alright friends those are the top five
in our list but of course let us know
what your favorite spanish language film
is in the comments and be sure
to head on over to runtomatos.com if you
want to check out the full list
and for more discussion and celebration
during hispanic heritage month come find
me in our fan group on facebook it is
muy caliente
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show be sure to
hit that subscribe button and
notification bell so you're covered
there
and as always muchas gracias for
watching the ketchup my name's nas perez
and hasta luego adios
[Music]
you